bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono felice io ci sono sono
sono tipo di avere siamo sud e su aim
che in italiano significa il villino che
è un gioco horror che però tra l'altro è
stato votatissimo in positivo e quindi
sono molto curioso perché non ho
veramente votato un sacco e molto corto
dura una mezz'oretta e vi assuma la
trama perché l'hanno appena descritto è
entrata una tipa in casa del
protagonista di sua moglie perché c'è
una moglie il protagonista sono io bello
e a guardare volevo usare il telefono ha
chiesto di usare il telefono non l'ha
usato e poi andata via
quindi ha semplicemente ispezionato la
casa quindi sta arrivando qualcuno
questo è quello che è successo
madonna mai fatto benissimo scherzavo si
presentava è il primo gioco nella storia
di steam secondo me che dalle foto è
peggio che quando ti giochi e meglio
cioè non solo usciti la mia ragazza e mi
e nel bagno e non voglio disturbarlo ok
e allora perché non leggiamo questo
libro di crimine e punizioni ok tedesche
ok devo prendere questa cosa
la carta dei tarocchi shell exxon che
riduca la lasciata la ragazza che è
entrata in casa ha lasciato un tarocco
ok e quindi non ho capito ho trovato
però non come fa eccola qua che è
successo
ragazzi si sta pagando il gioco che è
successo oddio amore che si sta pagando
la doccia vela ma con cui saltato di un
giorno ma cosa alle tre del mattino da
christie's
se avete visto giorgio sapete di cosa
stiamo parlando non c'è mia moglie nel
letto cosa è successo a mora e dove sei
ma vai sempre nel cesso e mia moglie ma
vive nel cesso sono arrivate voglia di
fare la vita lo c'è una cosa mia moglie
vive nel bagno in tutto questo va bene
niente quindi scendiamo anno aspetta
prendo la lanterna nel che stava nicolò
restava lanterna nell'armadio ha detto
giusto ragazze all'armadio ma eccolo qua
dettori stack
eccola qui anni già perfetto certo che
comunque se manca la corrente la prima
cosa che ti vien in mente e andare in
cantina a prendere il genoa donna che a
roma o rio piuttosto che fare una cosa
del genere
rimango tutta la notte nel letto non
faccio non andrei mai in cantina da solo
di notte ma lo guarda hanno fatto anche
il retro davy but i'm ha fatto benissimo
magari un gioco pazzesco per un euro
quindi siamo nel 1968 ok c'è un on the
power dry a posto adesso torno su e mia
moglie credo sia in bagno suino su lino
il caso 6 o dio se c'hai dei magneti
attaccati alle ginocchia perché ne sono
la stessa cosa
roma niente da te vai via fuori fuori
dalle palle
tanto come hai fatto entrare contavo
visto prima ma ragazzi dobbiamo
continuare a fissarci negli occhi tutto
il tempo andiamo lì sopra effettivamente
non ho capito il senso forse madonna ma
inquietante su santo iddio da wanna go
over there grazie un grandissimo manco
io vado di sopra dove c'è mia moglie
no non vado di sopra vado di qua devo
andare posso andare da mia moglie tu sei
proprio magro zio fatto di reno ragazzi
non ho capito quando da mia moglie
tesoro se ancora nel bagno rimani nel
bagno perché secondo me qua è un
problema di suini non identificati cioè
nel senso ci sono suini ma come
mercoledì ma cosa mercoledì cos'è che
poi fai a farmi un salto temporale dopo
sta cosa come mercoledì la torre alle
tre del pomeriggio è misin debba forma
game ormai non ho più dubbi
posso prendere lanterna o me ne vado
senza tanto ormai non ha prendiamo
dunque è passato un altro giorno i suini
se ne sono andati mi hanno tipo
ipnotizzato una roba del genere cioè non
saranno d'ore cheval che arriva dalla
cantina andiamo in cantina
[Musica]
saranno tutti lì dalla sotto che vi devo
dire e spuntata questa che non c'era un
mocio nuovo non c'era prima
no certo suino whatsapp non c'è più il
suino ciò è morto qua dentro non c'è
neanche un morto dove ad ora arriva a
suo dire che ne so io
sento un odore strano ma non c'è non lo
sento che dal computer non ci sono gli
odori purtroppo sarebbe molto figo di
questa feature non sei puzza di merda o
però c'è una cassetta c'è una cassetta
vhs la vado a vado a vedere cos'è di
sopra c'è un lettore vhs qualche parte
un lettore vhs matteo vhs non c'è un
lettore vhs eccolo molto bene e parti
hanno effettiva telo sia celle place no
un cazzo avevo fatto bene realistico dal
televisore anno accendiamo 11 8 2020 ma
cosa che siamo nel 68 ama il calendario
è vecchio
allora niente ci sta tutto il calendario
era vecchio pensa vostro calendario
recente a casa mia questa non l'ho
capito
raga si può anche uscire ma quanto bella
sia casa mi piacete guarda ma è
bellissimo
peccato per le zanzare prove come fa un
capanno di legno ad avere l'apertura col
codice a cosa
ok ragazzi ve lo dico l'ho guardato
perché non ho capito dove dove cacchio
era sto codice per sono sincero perché 0
e sono stato un ora a cercarlo per tutta
la casa non l'ho trovato quindi ho
guardato anche se non riuscivo più
scusatemi ma non ho capito dove si
prendeva comunque larve o a santo iddio
mi chiamò cha la presa la presa ha preso
lascia la preso lascia ha preso l'arci
al bellissimo ai remember now cosa cazzo
di membri
quindi niente mal di testa a domandare
ammazza la mia moglie ai tipo salve
ragazzi
vado a ucciderla io faccio io che senso
ha sto già ma perché mi ha ipnotizzato
perché devo fare io non la voglio fare
questa cosa perché mi dovete costringere
maiali di me more more è trovato
quell'odore da dove arriva friday eight
friday fare e in tutto questo non ho
idea di dove sia finita mi amor forse è
già successo qualcosa e non me lo
ricordo tipo con l'ascia potrebbe anche
essere effettivamente comunque lascia
non non ce l'ho più in mano
mannaggia al cacchio mi sto trovando
bene lo fa fuori suini che succede o
santo iddio ragazzi però basta che
cacchio e fateli cassino andate in un
account che mi chiami civico sono io
questo paese che casa eccola due ore per
trovare sagra ragazzi grazie grazie armi
nascosto le robe la chiave aperto il
bagno amore madonna sangue hanno fatto
malissimo a lorica cosa fatta male il
suo gioco perché per il resto tesoro
muore
100 bis b nella vasca da bagno tutto a
posto
posso aprire quanto teso tesoro possa
aprire la vasca non vorrei tanto aprirla
per un po in sonoro ma domattina gioco
c'è un tarocco potrà punta rocca mario
vado è sei qua sotto mi dispiace ma c'è
nella carta igienica qua volendo e se da
voi devo fare devo usare devo andare
devole marmi dalle palle emiliano delle
parti c'è anche un equilibrista casa sul
censo fuori dal centro ci sono solo
libri invio o un tarocco che metto col
con bach online volta rocco per posso
mettere il tarocco sulla
c'era anche prima questo va beh sai che
non mi ricordo se c'era questo prima
muore sei tu ok cielo piazzato sopra
anche se non me lo fa vedere che la
piazza
ok lo fa vedere tesoro perciò addio
l'ascia insanguinata prendi la prendi la
camera ti difendi se ti difendi un cazzo
sono io il carnefice quadrato no no no
no va bene senti però non mi poi fa
giocaste robe che cacchio che cacchio io
volevo il family non guadagni
il mio lavoro ma che cadeva fare
saturday
damon dei happy days to save the happy
trasformation va bene si è staccata la
porta ma tanto mi stupisce più niente
ragazzi però se siete ospiti non è che
fate il cazzo che volete io va bene non
so cosa dire avanti ho fatto quello che
volevano a te ha detto ma perché l'ha
fatto perché lo volevano
mi scusi torni a casa sua
l'amore ho fatto quello ce ne stesso uno
ti dice di ammazza la moglie lo fi ma
che sei scemo parte di qua è pieno di
social
[Musica]
ah no ok c'è ancora qualcosa o figo
ragazzi sono qua che succede sono i
tarocchi c'è mia moglie ci lascia c'è il
prete don gino idol speak english storia
che newspeak lead icepeak lido english
che new jersey jessica uso perfetto
patrick e dalla madonna effettivamente
non solo faceva lui sto gioco per un
euro e cinquanta affacciò gaffe sarà the
science proprio video vi sia piaciuto
porto sempre contenuti che non mi fanno
dormire e speriamo di incontrare mai a
lista no perché video di 6.100 momento
mi piace iscrive al canale e noi come
sempre ragazzi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]
ma